[Music]
can we add up all the clues of this
board ape crypto nazi situation i
watched phillian's thing you watched it
i watched the whole thing same that's
one of those ones that's just fun you
know it's one of those conspiracies
that's just like oh man it was classic
this was true [ __ ] it's so juicy it felt
like that classic 2008 dude look up
michael jordan parody conspiracy do you
remember this let it play listen this
dude's voice it's so [ __ ] funny
syrians and babylonians worshipped
offshore yo bump that [ __ ] because the
eagle is l the wings of the air the
egyptian solar disk and you'll see that
companies like chrysler use the wing
disk because it represents offshore bill
in lille or saturn and that's real god's
son
christ slayer uses the instagram and the
pentagon remember i told you the symbol
for fear is the prince of satan well let
me tell you the truth about michael
jordan
because he is the prince of the air
and michael is the arch angel that
defeated satan which is blasphemy
because satan is the prince of the air
the bear air floating that's why michael
plays on the chicago
bulls the red bull of l the red
winged bull flying through the air
because the ancient babylonians and
assyrians worship the winged bull and
that's why he's named michael jordan
because jordan is where they worship the
winged bowl and why do you think they
play with a ball
because ball comes from baal and that's
why you use sex magic and put the ball
in the hole and that's why it makes me
sick seeing little children holding
their balls for michael jordan to sign
oh my god this is so good this is how
phillians think yeah yeah yeah yeah if
you haven't seen it it's called board a
nazi club it sort of claims that the
board api club is
premised on like a
sort of a overarching theme of like
white supremacy i will say like i think
it's like a weird mutual exclusivity
thing like the inspiration for some of
these things could very well be like
these 4chan like terms and ideas and
references to the culture that is on
that board but like i don't think
they're as calculated as he's leading on
like i just think it's like four dudes
who are like yo let's just start an nft
project yeah and then just kind of
injected some
references in there and i will say some
of it does make me go like um hey how
did you how did you land there there
were definitely moments where i'm like
uh that's a bit close me too yeah and
but like the craziest part of it was the
[ __ ] logo so the normal like the
totem cough is normally in a circle and
the outside of the circle is not
perfectly straight it's like a little
wavy yeah which the board api club logo
also has just the fact that it's like a
sideways skull with the two things on
either side with the text above and
below it's like way too similar i didn't
bother counting but like supposedly like
the board ape has 18 teeth and yeah all
four of the founders technically aren't
you know they're they're not all like
white it would be a strange
thing if they were like white
supremacists because you know i don't
think white supremacists would like at
least three of them this came across so
funny because he was trying to establish
all these nuanced things about a board
that no one uses and the way he did it
was so intense that i felt like it it
almost took away his credibility because
he made it seem so like and they say
keck which is a reference to world of
warcraft and like it made you like
okay yeah but it's that was for people
like me that didn't know that
fair you know i like i i used to go on
4chan but i never was that super deep
into it so i never like picked up on
some of those memes and pepe and all
that stuff like that was a little bit
foreign to me i was familiar with the
concept but that actually helped me be
like oh [ __ ] i felt like if he just
established some of these things without
such a because he comes in really heavy
like this is undeniable proof that these
people are white supremacists yeah and i
think that's what backed him into a
corner yeah you know they're gonna sue
him out the [ __ ] ass you think so
yeah they're gonna press him here's what
i think is kind of damning on
their part and now they made a response
video because i it seems like the nazi
symbolism was kind of percolating before
this came out yeah ryder rips was the
one that i think yeah yeah yeah
yeah so ryder rips kind of put that
thing out then they make a response and
then on the yugo labs website is this
big response letter and some of their
responses are so sort of like it's
almost like condescending we've
addressed this already and like you it's
almost like you [ __ ] morons like and
then they kind of say some things one of
the funniest parts to me was they kept
referencing the adl the anti-defamation
league or whatever like we consulted
with the adl and they say
clean and clear like this is not true
and i laughed i'm like who at the adl
under has ever been on 4chan to qualify
any of this [ __ ] yeah we got a contact
at the adl he's our 4chan expert oh yeah
you're saying like a government agency
it's just like some random ass like [ __ ]
with boomers in there like yo they said
our nft is like nazi propaganda it's
like can you take a look and tell us if
it is or isn't it look like a bunch of
monkeys to me yeah
as fun of a conspiracy as it is they're
just four guys yeah that just like made
an nft project with monkeys in it didn't
really think that hard about it woke up
and we're like wait what yeah an hour
long documentary about how we're all
nazis what the [ __ ] it'd be like waking
up to us like somebody makes a
documentary like cody noel or like
actually vampires or something yeah even
though that like whole segment in the
middle about that test that they did
that that's pretty [ __ ] crazy it
makes me think like these guys are not
stupid like they're they think a lot
about symbolism and drawing things well
the relationship between things in their
response letter that part was a little
that part to me felt a little like like
there were some politicians because they
were like oh um
we didn't come up with that we had to
hire someone and they threw someone
under the bus the way they address it is
by releasing another set of nfts
super in demand super hyped up yeah it's
called the anti-racist board apes yeah
yeah that's how they do it yeah so
unfortunately guys since the crypto
crash don't actually have enough money
to rebrand so we're gonna need some more
money yeah but that's the point that
they just make 200 million dollars off
this new set and they're like cool we're
all good right yeah
all good something about it like this
whole response letter it felt a little
prideful yeah it was almost like uh it
didn't address the point it was sort of
like how are you going to accuse us
a jewish man a pakistani man a a
you know a cuban man of being white
supremacist like why wouldn't you guys
come out and say yo
this was like a gross oversight this is
making us reconsider the brand a little
bit um we're gonna take some time to
like kind of evaluate because we don't
even want it to be a sense of like any
degree of this feeling like it's in this
tone yeah we've responded to much of
this [ __ ] before i don't know i
think in a situation where you're being
identified as having like some very very
like bigoted symbolism that is like a
core part of your product i just think
you would approach it a little bit
differently than that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah
so far-fetched i would like them to be
like yeah our logo [ __ ] it kind of does
look like this yeah right yeah damn wow
it's really similar we're sorry about
this
sounds really similar some degree of
empathy and there's just like none
caught us
we are actually nazis damn phillion
[ __ ]
supernazis man we thought we were being
pretty low-key about it but we are
indeed nazis nazi balls in your mouth